if you're not familiar
um when does social media come out 2008
2000 well before 2008 we had myspace
2008 9-ish or so i think some people
signed up to facebook around 2007
but it was around that time 2009 or so
facebook became prominent then we had
you know twitter and the instagram and
all the other stuff that came out around
that now we've got tick tocks and
snapchats all this stuff and um
it is it is engineered to have you
addicted to it um
guys aren't as susceptible as women are
guys are more addicted to things like
dopamine hits from video games and
consoles and their mobile devices with
games and [ __ ] like that
women are more addicted to the dopamine
hits that they get from
approval and validation of other people
and i'm going to tell you why in a
second
we've been operating as i mean
i'm going to call it humanoids but
basically our our
ancestors separated from primates around
six to seven million years ago
okay that's when the human lineage began
and split from the primates chimpanzees
grills and all that kind of [ __ ]
uh first modern humans homo sapiens were
200 000 years ago
uh did you stone tool technology was 2.6
million years ago sorry
i'm jumping around here 12 000 years ago
they say
somewhere between 12 and 10 000 years
ago agriculture kicked in and we started
you know abandoning the hunting
gathering lifestyle for more of a
uh uh fixed you know permanent position
you know we started growing [ __ ] we had
oxen and deer and you know we farmland
and stuff like that
but prior to that we were mostly nomadic
hunter-gatherers and the interesting
thing about that
and by the way primates go back 55
million years we're not just talking
like the six to seven
million years ago that we separated from
the primate lineage primates go back
55 million years so this is this is a
sequence of of genomes that have been
going on for
tens of millions of years okay social
media has only been around for
12 years so if you think that we've
evolved in the last 12 years to adapt to
be able to
deal with the technology that's
hardwired into social media into these
i say little handheld devices but these
damn things keep getting bigger and
bigger
but you know handheld devices we've not
even come
close okay to being able to know how to
adapt and how to deal with that
um i read a book four or five years ago
near ayel who's the author of the book's
called hooked
i'd recommend reading it if you go to
the pin top comment of any of my videos
i got a recommended reading list
i spent a lot of time listening to books
when i'm going about my day when i'm not
doing [ __ ] around the house
and this is a great one and it explains
how they engineer
um addictive traits into
all technologies from uh video games
um you know this book goes as far back
to talk about
more uh like some of the more
groundbreaking ones like
what was that one world of warcraft um
and it's fully engineered in everything
social media you get the the bongs the
bells the dings the alerts the hearts
the
hey somebody liked your picture somebody
commented on your picture
you know you get a dm people get
dopamine hits from this
they say that the dopamine hits are as
similar as uh cocaine
you know dopamine hits i'm not sure that
they're you know that strong
but you know it's it's obviously pretty
significant because when you look around
at people it doesn't matter where you
are walking down the street at the bus
stop at the gym
they're just sitting here with their
head down people in about 50 years are
gonna have bent necks like this right
because we're spending so much time
staring at a freaking handheld device
it's not good um there's a few shows
that have been out lately
i didn't get a chance to watch the
interview that joe rogan did with uh i
can't remember
what was his name tristan harris but the
social dilemma is on netflix go watch
the social dilemma on netflix
and spend some time uh paying attention
to evo psych um
there's a very good book i finished the
last couple months i think it's called
the evolution of desire
um that's also pinned in the amazon
bookstore that i always mentioned you
guys
check those out so
the thing that you got to understand is
for women to have survived
for as long as they have with their
offspring they
needed to have the approval of the
others in the nomadic hunter-gatherer
tribes
which by the way operated that way for a
very long period of time we're talking
55 million years
okay then we go back 10 12 million years
we've moved to agriculture
moving from nomadic hunter-gatherers to
agriculture to slowly
you know trying to shift over to
a completely different lifestyle and
then here we are 12 years now
we've had these handheld digital devices
that give you wicked dopamine hits
that people that people and you know
more specifically women have been
looking for
for tens of millions of years and they
needed the approval of the tribe they
needed the approval of the others in the
tribe
because their survival depended on it
you could throw a guy out as long as he
had his weapons he'd probably find ways
to
you know hunt gather find food he'll set
up a new tribe right
but women the weaker sex did not have
that privilege
so it so they relied on the approval of
the others
okay in the nomadic hunter-gatherer
tribes and by the way
they weren't you know the world
population of whatever it is 8 billion
people now
it was a population of probably 50 or
less
25 50 it was usually no more than 75
based on the
information that i've collected so very
very small groups
but the difference today though is women
don't know the difference between that
small group of 50 that they needed the
approval of for survival
to the 8 billion people in the world any
woman can go and download an
a instagram or a tick tock or a
snapchatty app or whatever
and have a public profile and when they
post a provocative sexy picture
they will get instant gratification they
will get the approval
of others because their hind brain has
been programmed to seek the approval of
others of the
nomadic hunter-gatherer tribes but only
on a larger scale
and they're drunk on it and there's
nothing wrong with that that's just the
way that things are
so when you understand why they have
this addiction and why they behave that
way and why they go
seeking the hits and they don't even
understand that they're doing this i
mean
you can have the greatest chick in the
world you know you think in your life
all of them are going to have some
addiction to social if they have a phone
they're going to have some addiction to
social media
it's a fact of life you're not going to
get around it okay
so how do you deal with that how do you
break that
well it's going to take a little bit of
work i'll be honest with you
because like as i speak right now
social media companies are hiring people
that they call attention engineers okay
what they do is they find better ways to
keep your attention
on the handheld devices they do it i
mean men respond to things differently
from women women are
very very simple i mean if you've paid
any attention you've been
been around enough women you've probably
noticed that if they have a social media
account they post something and they
don't get enough
validation or attention on it it'll get
deleted it'll disappear
and they'll find a more provocative way
and it's very easy for them like they've
figured out these um angles
different ways to you know get that you
know make it work a little higher get a
little more booby a little more down
back over here gets the bomb curve
i got my guests here in the waiting area
i'll be right with you bro stand by
give me like two more minutes
so how do you break it it's very very
simple
if she's in your frame and she defers to
you and she respects you
and she has genuine burning desire for
you
this is very important though because
there's always going to be an
opportunity to have
the talk right guys aren't supposed to
have the talk
weak men have the talk they'll be like
where do we stand you know we've been
dating for a while and i really like you
and i hope
we could be something together and
boyfriend girlfriend guys don't have the
talk
don't do the talk let her bring the talk
to you
let her come at you and be like yeah you
know we've been dating for a while and i
don't want to
do it and i want to be with you okay
fine let her bring the talk to you
it's very very important that you let
her bring the talk to you because when
it comes to this when you're going to
break this habit
when she's looking for something more
long-term more intimate on a more
personal basis and you're going to
invite her into your inner life
this is something that you're going to
have to break and it's as simple as this
girlfriends that have boyfriends don't
post provocative pictures of themselves
on social media
the difference between men and women the
male sexual strategy is unlimited access
to unlimited women
okay it's as simple as that we want to
scatter our seed that's what we're here
to do that's what we do
women on the other hand want the best
that they can get
picture a soccer pitch or a hockey arena
you know whatever it is that you want to
use
okay you're in the arena you're playing
the game
for the guy playing the game he's
spinning plates he's smashing
he's dating a bunch of chicks maybe he's
spinning plates and let the cream rise
to the top whatever strategy it is that
he wants to use
the female sexual strategy is open
hypergamy
she's looking for the best that she can
get so if she's still posting
sexy provocative pictures to the world
on social media apps and she's come to
you had the talk
and she sees you as the best that she
can do it's very simple
girlfriends with boyfriends don't post
sexy provocative pictures on social
media she'll abandon it
if she's in your frame and all those
things are in place if not
tell her get lost i've i've told women
look insert whatever it is that i'm i'm
stating to them if you don't like it the
front door is over there [ __ ] off
take your [ __ ] get out of here and [ __ ]
off okay
if she's in your frame she will yield if
she doesn't see you as the best that she
can do
what is she going to do she's going to
protest she's going to call you
controlling
blah blah blah okay you have to learn
how to break it and it's not that hard
but it's only not that hard if she
respects you and she's in your frame
you